thanks very much indeed hello and
welcome to the Daily climate show coming
up I sleep at the wheel the UK's climate
Watchdog warns the government that it
needs to speed up the decarbonization of
the power sector
the biggest producer of oil and gas in
the North Sea says the windfall tax was
all but wiped out their two billion
pound profits for the year
and new research suggests that smoke
from the Australian bushfires in 2020
depleted the ozone layer by up to five
percent
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now the UK's climate Watchdog has warned
that the government will miss its Target
of decarbonizing the UK's Energy System
by 2035 unless they make urgent changes
to the system the latest report from the
climate change committee stressed that
an energy system dominated by Renewables
is achievable by 2035 but the government
needs to remove Regulatory and planning
barriers to allow investors to take
advantage well Skies climate reporter
Victoria Seabrook joins me now so
Victoria tell us more then about what's
in this report what's the watchdog's
main point here
well the key Point really is that we are
running out of time that there is still
time but it's running low to clean up
Britain's electricity Network so when
they say clean up they mean Riddick of
carbon emissions that is going to be
crucial for us hitting our climate
targets but also have other impacts
potentially reducing air pollution
things like that now this challenge has
really taken on another dimension in the
last year as we've really uh focused
much more on the question of energy
security and something that people have
been asking more and more is well if we
are going to clean up the electricity
system which by and large means getting
it off fossil fuels and onto clean power
what happens when the wind doesn't blow
and the sun doesn't shine now this
report is really an answer to that
question and it says actually it's
doable here is the plan the plan is we
can get around 70 of our electricity
from renewable even with the big
increase in demand that we're expecting
as we move more on to electric cars and
heat pumps for our homes things like
that so 70 from Renewables and then the
remainder a mix of things like nuclear
hydrogen tiny bit of gas for backup and
a few other things so they're saying
look this is doable but we really need
to start acting and ministers have been
much too slow now the government says we
are the fastest economy in the G7 to
decarbonize we are a world leader in Net
Zero certainly they have been very quick
with their target but the advisors are
just worried that that we're falling
behind they said they've been in
Brussels ministers there are moving more
quickly and they're worried that any
crucial decision things like planning
and regulation investment that you just
mentioned are going to be those
decisions are going to be left until
after the next general election which
we're expecting in the next 18 months
what their looking for with this report
today Landing just a week before the
budget is for some key commitments from
the chancellor next week I mean while
you've also spotted something on biomass
haven't you so talk us through that
yeah so biomass is something that we
have covered a lot on Sky News it's a
slightly controversial form of
generating electricity which involves
which involves burning wood that makes
the industry eligible for big
governments uh so it makes the industry
eligible for big subsidies Drax the UK's
largest generator of bioenergy receives
600 million pounds last year now the
advisors are saying that that helped the
industry get up up and running but now
it's not delivering good value for money
so that's quite a strong message and I
think we're going to hear more and more
about bioenergy as we increasingly talk
about Britain's Energy Future
interesting stuff Victoria thanks very
much indeed
now the biggest producer of oil and gas
in the North Sea has criticized the
government's energy windfall tax after
its profits were all but wiped out
Harbor energy has said it's reduced its
UK investment it's now looking to expand
elsewhere as a result of the hit from
the windfall tax
wahhaba's full year pre-tax profits were
2.46 billion dollars that's up from 315
million dollars in 2021 but their profit
after the windfall tax was just eight
million dollars compared to 101 million
the year before
well let's get more on their Skies a
business presenter Ian King joins me now
and uh in afternoon to you the windfall
tax on oil and gas has been criticized
by some as not going far enough but a
very different line being taken today by
Harbor energy
absolutely I mean this is a company that
it should not be forgotten is the
biggest producer of oil and gas in the
North Sea it was uh formed by a series
of Acquisitions it bought shells North
Sea assets for three billion dollars
back in 2017 it brought Conoco
Phillips's North Sea operations for 2.7
billion dollars in 2019 so this is a
very major player it employs 1500 people
all of whom are involved in uh
production in the North Sea now the
company has said in response to this
windfall tax it is going to cancel two
projects and it's likely to have to cut
jobs so this is clear evidence that the
windfall tax is going to cost jobs in
the UK oil and gas sector and it's worth
remembering the North Sea is a very very
mature Basin anyway uh it's certainly
peaked in terms of the amount of energy
that can be extracted from it and so
companies like Harper effectively
turning their back on it means the
situation is going to get a lot worse
and Linda cook the chief executive has
made this very clear she says this has
driven to us to reduce our UK investment
and Staffing levels and they as you said
are going to be looking to invest more
overseas now they're not the only
company that's spoken out about this
today Neptune which is another privately
owned North Sea oil and gas company
they've also said that the tax is
undermining investment and it's
undermining also the long-term energy
security of the UK and uh what the all
this comes it should be remembered Anna
is at a time when the United States is
absolutely incentivizing energy
companies to invest in long-term
projects and what's Happening Here is
the exact opposite the government is
effectively taxing it it's also worth
bearing in mind that there's also a
generator Levy which is another windfall
tax effectively that's been put on the
windfall uh on the energy sector the the
wind farm producers and there too are
very very unhappy about this and saying
it threatens their investment a lot of
these businesses are owned by big global
companies for example Scottish Power
it's owned by a bedroller of Spain they
can invest all over the world they don't
have to invest here in the United
Kingdom and these windfall taxes makes
it less likely that they will do so okay
Ian interesting thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the news and new
Research into Wildfire smoke suggests it
causes chemical reactions which
contribute to the destruction of the
ozone layer the findings published in
the journal Nature found that smoke from
the 2019 and 2020 Australian bushfires
temporarily depleted the ozone layer by
up to five percent
the findings increase concerns that more
frequent and intense wildfires could
delay ozone recovery as the climate
warms
a new investigation has found the
distance electric cars can drive in
winter is up to a third less than
advertised what car magazine tested
fully charged cars which had been left
outside in temperatures just above
freezing the team found cold weather
negatively affects battery performance
and efficiency especially if the car's
heating system is in use
testing of so-called forever chemicals
in England's wild fish has found high
levels of pollutants that have eaten
more than twice a year would exceed
recommended EU safety guidelines pfas
and pfos are pollutants that don't break
down in the environment and link to
health conditions in humans if consumed
the data obtained by Watershed
investigations found the highest
pollutant readings were in the Thames
mersey and wire
now before we go we want your climate
questions anything that's ever mystified
you about the environment or whatever
you want to get to the bottom of just
scan this QR code and send us your
questions which we'll answer in the
climate Show with Tom Heap and you can
watch Tom's show on Saturday and Sunday
at 3 30 pm here on Sky News and he's
been in Cheshire looking into plans for
a hydrogen Village this week and not
everyone there is terribly happy about
those plans
thanks for watching that's all from us
for today
[Music]